hi everyone my name is Jamie McClellan I
am going to be speaking to you today
about my poster on the characterization
of immunodeficient mouse models that we
have available at in B go so the purpose
of our study that we did was just to
evaluate the immune phenotype in some of
our immunodeficient mouse models that we
have it in me go so when we talking
about skid nice we're talking about a
spontaneous mutation and PRK DC gene
that leads to highly a variant genetic
rearrangements that impair the function
of T and B cells by not allowing them to
generate T cell receptors or
immunoglobulins however some skid mice
according to the literature about two to
twenty percent randomly produce
functional rearrangements in the DNA
allowing for functional T cell receptors
or heavy chains for antibody production
and these cells can actually go on to
survive and expand and leading to the
production of a measurable serum igg and
these mice are considered leaky so on
the methods that we use for this study
were blood splatters dried blood spot
collections at 12 16 20 and 24 weeks of
age and those samples were sent off to
New idexx bio research or msi analysis
of iqg and we did meet cropsey's at six
months of age to look for the incidence
of thymic lymphoma and they started with
23 first ring so the first stream that
we looked at was our cv 17 skid and we
and we have in the dark grey bars are
the males and the green bars are the
females and we have igg measurements the
percentage of animals that were over 5
micrograms per mil of serum igg from 12
16 20 and 24 weeks of age
and then the next stream that we looked
at was our CD 17 skidded with the list
beige mutation which reduces NK cell
activity and then the next strain was
the skid model on an odd background and
then we also looked at our Shore model
which is the non skid with a hairless
mutation crossed it as well and if we
look at all of this data together it
just shows us that our animals confirm
with the literature saying that two to
twenty percent about of skid mice become
weak over their lifetime so we also
looked at survival and these in these
models and notice at 24 weeks of age or
about six months of age that over eighty
percent of our animals still survive to
six months of age of these your
immunodeficient mice and then with our
58 lymphoma incidents also confers with
what we find in the literature at six
months of age with less than thirty
percent developing funded almost six
pounds of age so the immune phenotype
can vary depending on multiple things
including the background strain whether
it's a b-17 skids or the nods goods age
as well that they can increase with age
it can also depend on extra mutations
that are on the on these backgrounds
such as the list page mutation affecting
in case cell activity and then a major
one is housing environment which can be
considered barrier versus isolator
raised animals which is pretty much just
the health standard of the animals that
are available so we still need
additional studies to confirm immune
cell activity and function which will be
useful to further characterize these
models but these data still provide
valuable information to determine the
best to help us help our clients
determine the best models for their
xenograft research thank you
you